jazz waters a writer for this is us has
died at the age of 39 her cause of death
has not been revealed at this time the
official this is us writers account
confirmed the news on Wednesday sharing
quote the entire this is us family was
devastated to learn of jazz waters
passing in our time together
jazz left her mark on us and all over
the show she was a brilliant storyteller
and a force of nature
in addition to the hit NBC show waters
worked on Jim Carrey's kidding
hood adjacent with James Davis and the
2019 movie what men want for me
personally I can name some really
amazing women who have helped me get to
where I am right now under the name jazz
fly she starred on the gossip Game a vh1
reality series centered around bloggers
and other media figures covering the
music industry this is hip hop hip hop
is built off of competition competition
is okay it makes you better
waters this is us family paid tribute to
her on social media show creator Dan
Fogelman tweeted this news took my
breath away jazz was absolutely
brilliant and had so many stories still
to tell she made an incredible mark on
our show and my heart breaks for her
loved ones Mandy Moore posted sending
love and light to jazz fly's family and
loved ones in a snow-covered hoo-hoos
Christine Metz honored waters writing I
am praying for your beautiful transition
jazz may it be full of love light and
peace thank you for the time we shared
your fearlessness and inspiration it
becomes a challenge to write something
that's so profound and powerful but also
take the audience on a journey you don't
always have to do that with you know the
naughty stuff or you know the very adult
things and I think that's such a
testament to the writers and the
creativity and just the real sincerity